welcome back it is Las Vegas vegan
dining month and to celebrate I'm so
excited to have you guys here in the
kitchen with me the owners of Taco
Terrian Kristen and Carlos Corral and
they're here kind of showing off
plant-based foods and you know before we
get started first of all congratulations
you guys on your incredible success here
in the valley one store quickly turned
into four and now one in San Diego Kudos
awesome thank you so much A lot of
people when they find out I'm a
plant-based eater they're like well what
do you eat
so many options out there so explain to
Folks at home who may not be super aware
of what's going on with veganism and the
movement that's really kind of taking
steam what do you eat what what do we
eat here yeah I think there's like a
misconception that people eat like tofu
and salad if you're vegan and that
hardly and any of the things that I
personally eat or that we eat at home
vegan food can be anything and you know
when we created Taco Terrian we wanted
just food that was so good that you
don't even know it's vegan I love that
people just come in and they're like oh
wow that was vegan if that's vegan I
could eat that like this for example so
Carlos what are you making here uh this
is one of the big annular specials this
is the second tacos so it's a flour
tortilla and it has fried beans mashed
potatoes chorizo it's pan fried and then
we top it off with some coleslaw some
Crema Salsas and a little bit of Pico de
Gallo on top of it awesome and you say
chorizo of course it's not the typical
chorizo it's like soy based yes is that
right it is yes I gotta tell you my
husband who is a big time meat eater he
came here and was like wait what there's
no meat in this he couldn't tell he
loved it so some of the other items that
you guys feature big uh I mean you have
such a following what can people expect
when they come into taco Terrian what do
you got um well they can expect a good
time they can expect amazing Margaritas
but we brought a couple of our most
popular things here's our cauliflower
Ceviche so which is typically fish ours
is made with cauliflower um it's very
refreshing and light we've got a coconut
cake up front it's one of the best
things on the menu so that's this one
here the coconut cake okay and we've got
our takisi Lotte which is kind of
traditionally Lotte with chili mayo and
then we've kind of funded up with Takis
which is Mexican corn chips yum we've
got our blueberry cheesecake which again
is completely plant-based no dairy in
there and it's amazing and then we've
got our specials which is our veganuary
special so this is the beers one here
yeah so these are Iberia empanadas
they're really fun they're traditional
empanadas but they've got birya and
cheese in them and they come with a
dipping broth here and lime and onion
cilantro excellent so a lot of your
items too also on the menu for folks who
might be gluten free they are labeled
such as so yeah you know kind of what
you can eat if you have any kind of food
allergies Etc uh really quick you know
it is veganuary and I know Diane Edelman
and uh vegan's baby she's created this
entire month for restaurants here in
town like yourselves to kind of get
involved why is this important and and
kind of tell us where we can go to find
out a little bit more if people want to
test out the vegan food yeah so Diana's
been doing veganuary for quite a while a
few years now and we've participated
every year it's a really fun way for us
personally to bring some new dishes get
people excited about trying new things
but be January and vegan dining month in
general is a chance for people who may
not be plant-based all the time to kind
of like dabble you know there's like dry
January and things like that like try
something new get out there try a
plant-based meal you don't have to eat
plant-based every day but incorporate a
couple meals a week into your diet and I
think you'll really enjoy it yeah I mean
you know we've we've certainly heard
it's good for health that's one of the
reasons I switched over but if you're an
animal lover too that may inspire you
okay I just got to show off this dish
one more time look at that oh my gosh
you guys incredible stuff okay we're
gonna put all this information on the
website for you go check out Taco
Terrian but make sure you kind of
somehow hit up one of the restaurants
try a vegan menu item you'll be
surprised I know my husband was guys
Kristen thank you thank you so much
thank you so much for being here